Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Nein, das ist irgendein Mega Man Soundtrack.
Easykiller, dankeschön für den Sub.
19 Monate Hypersubscription, extrem hier.
Hypersubscriber, Hypersubscriber.
Nein, es steht heute, heute steht nicht großartig was an.
Ich hab gedacht, ich komm lieber noch mal on, bevor ich nicht on komme.
Und deswegen hab ich nix großartiges zu.
Kampf Kevin, sei mal was das.
Shortest Useful Restart.
Ja, das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Das ist unglaublich wie oft es hilft.
Das hilft, so unglaublich wie oft Rebooten hilft.
Kann man der krasseste Herrkermann sein, nicht wissen woran es liegt Reboot und gut ist.
Ich kenn den Channel, das meiste find ich jetzt nicht so spannend, weil hauptsächlich steht er halt vor der Kamera und erzählt und zeigt nix.
Und ganz ehrlich, so wie jetzt der Windows-Taskmanager genau funktioniert, juckt mich hauptsächlich.
Also ich weiß, ich kenn das Video, ich guck auch ab und zu mal was von ihm.
Er hat letztens beispielsweise auch sein Heimnetzwerk gezeigt, das war auch äußerst unspektakulär.
Moin.
Es haben alle so cute Emotes hier.
Obbei ich ja auch, ich ja auch.
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich hab auch cute Emotes.
Ja, ich glaub schon, dass die echt sind. Gibt es da neue oder sind es immer noch die zwei von gestern?
Es gibt glaub ich keine neuen, oder?
Immer noch die gleichen, ja ne.
Ich glaub schon, dass die echt sind, zumindest das obere.
Reddit ist immer so lustig.
Null Reddit.
Wie lustig.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, aber gerade der obere sah recht legit aus.
Letztendlich juckt es mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich will, dass der Trailer, wenn der Trailer am Start ist.
Obwohl ich kann euch eh sagen, wie das laufen wird, weil es die letzten Jahre schon so gut war.
Obwohl ich kann euch eh sagen, wie das laufen wird, weil es die letzten Jahre schon so gelaufen ist.
Die machen...
Ups, weiß nicht so genau, warum ich das jetzt aufmache.
Die machen einen Mini-Teaser.
Zwei Sekunden.
Könnt ihr euch noch an Battlefield 1 erinnern, wo du den Soldat gesehen hast, der in die Luft geguckt hat, weil da so ein Luftschiff da rumgeflogen ist, was man nicht gesehen hat.
Zwei Sekunden Mini-Teaser.
Und dann ne Woche später kommt der richtige Trailer oder ein paar Tage später.
Genauso wird's laufen.
Oh ja, das bringt bestimmt richtig was.
Zulull.
Soll das... Ist das Doomfist?
Richtig, richtig, ein richtig nicees Zulull-Emote.
Der ist gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie... Die sind so unlustig auf dem Battlefield-Subreddit.
Also ich geh davon aus, auf meiner 1080 Ti kann ich ohne Probleme Battlefield 6 spielen.
Und ich spiele den ganzen Kram eh in Low-Settings.
Also scheiß drauf, warum sollte ich das...
Leute, ihr kennt mich, ich spiel sogar...
Ich spiel sogar Battlefield 3 in Niedrig mit ein paar Sachen.
Mit ein paar Sachen, ja.
Warum sollte ich denn jetzt gerade Battlefield 6 dann in Hoch spielen?
Was ist denn Hyper-Tapping überhaupt?
Kids, gucken wir uns das klar an.
Ich spiel sogar Tetris, ich spiel alles auf Low-Settings, ihr kennt mich doch.
Ah, hier.
Excellent Co-Comrade-Video.
Zeig her.
Pains champ die Chinesen wieder, ey.
Also ich dachte, da fährt jetzt drüber.
Die China-Chinesen.
Ich bin immer wieder gespannt, was mir YouTube so empfiehlt.
Ich interessiere mich nicht großartig für Hasen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Aber YouTube ist da Meinung.
20 ablenkende Kanickel ist genau der richtige Content für den Chat.
Aber die wissen halt, dass der Chat cute ist.
Ob's, das hab ich zugemacht.
Massive cute Chat.
24-hundert-Hasen-Abbleck-Stream, bestes.
Ja Chat, also auf geht's jetzt hier.
Ihr glaubt wohl, ich hab Witze gemacht mit Daily Scrum.
Also jeder, jetzt aber, Reihe um.
Das habt ihr heute erledigt.
Ansonsten ist die Abmahnung raus.
Wer sich nicht beteiligt am Daily Scrum, ist nicht agil genug für diesen Stream.
Bachelorarbeit, okay.
Sollen wir installieren, Bewerbung geschrieben, sehr gut.
Android-Entwicklung.
So installiert bewerbung geschrieben sehr gut android entwicklung
In in in muss ich mal fragen hast du in in java oder in irgendwas
nicht ganz so pains champion
Leute wir haben neues emote ich habe neues emote hinzugefügt vorhin weil ich das so lustig fand
Wo habe ich denn?
Ich finde es nicht. Irgendetwas mit sad pepo, sad
Sad
Sadge cry
Wenn jetzt ganz ganz pepehändige sachen passieren
haben wir sadge cry
Abschlussprüfung gelernt. Stimmt wann ist denn die abschlussprüfung leute wann ist denn die ab die die ist doch im juni oder so juni
Juli, august oder so ist die doch oder ist jetzt die frühjahrsprüfung
Das ist dann die die die verkürzerprüfung jetzt und die reguläre physikprüfung ist ja dann wahrscheinlich im juli august so
Also ich meine wir sind nicht so agil wie wir sind aber doch kein 15 minuten dafür
Am mittwoch achso
Sehr gut ja gut das ist jetzt das ist dann die die die verkürzerprüfung jetzt und die reguläre physikprüfung ist ja dann wahrscheinlich im
Im juli august so
Als die reguläre ist jetzt näh was
Im mai
Achso schriftliche prüfung schriftliche prüfung achso jaja ja das ist ja ja ihr habt recht ihr habt recht
Jaja klar ja ja schriftliche prüfung ist jetzt das ist richtig
Jetzt am mittwoch
Irk test prüfung pdf kommen wir gucken da jetzt mal testfragen prüfungsfragen für ausbilder eignen euren fizi fizi
Prüfungsvorbereitung aktuell das hatte ich schon mal auf und da habe ich glaube ich gedacht das kann ich nicht zeigen weil monka tos
Oder nähe um konntest du es nicht zeigen ach so weil es kann. Oh guck mal hier gibt es hier gibt es hier gibt es sogar testfragen
Nennen sie dem kunde drei vorteile der verwendung von subnetzen gibt kein einfach alles in ein netz
Und rgb also ich würde eher darauf verzichten
Dass alles in unterschiedliche netze aufzuteilen alles in ein netz machen und dafür ergibt sich ein netz
Und das alles in unterschiedliche netze aufzuteilen alles in ein netz machen und dafür rgb ins rechnzentrum das ist besser und man spart sich geräte
Also rgb ist eindeutig besser als ein ordentliches subnetz glaube da sind wir uns alle einig
Das bringt nix ich hab selbst noch alte prüfung das bringt aber nix weil ich die nicht zeigen kann im stream
Was rgb lagenkabel ja und und und wireless
skill killer drei monat lang für den sub
Machste blöd rüber wie über was soll ich blöder machen
Wenn ich das blöd rüber mache seht ihr die prüfung nicht
Funktioniert super und dann kann man nicht kann man es nicht sehen dass es ergibt ja keinen sicht
Nennen sie dem kunden drei fort ok jetzt mal serious cake wait leute
Cake wait also serious nennen sie dem kunden drei vorteile wir machen jetzt max max prüfungsvorbereitung
Aber nicht aber nicht so allzu langweil sonst allzu lang halte ich die iak das iak stellt hier nicht aus wir machen wir machen nur eins eine seite oder so
Nennen sie dem kunden drei vorteile der verwendung von subnetzen ok lasst mal in mich gehen was ist das
Nennen sie dem kunden drei vorteile der verwendung von subnetzen ok lasst mal in mich gehen was sind die verwendung von was sind die verwendung
Die vorteile für die verwendung von subnetzen ok was bei dir man muss iak denkweise machen muss iak denkweise machen iak denkweise
Wir möchten stichworte höre stichworte hören die die sie kennen broadcast domain beschränkung oder sowas ja
Broadcast domäne wollen die da bestimmt hören genau genau 100 pro ja bin ich mit ok es ist das erste das erste broadcast domäne
Also es ist heute nicht wirklich egal beschreiben wir broadcast domäne verkleiden was sind sonst noch die vorteile von subnetzen
Einfachere firewall also firewall also best security du kannst netze besser filtern untereinander ja kannst du firewall dazwischen machen
Tja was gibt es sonst noch so vorteile von subnetzen kannst vielleicht ip adress vergabe besser managen
Du kannst du kannst besser kannst es vielleicht so scheiße was wollen die da wissen du kannst das je nach du kannst vielleicht standorte besser aufteilen
Bessere organisation oder sowas gibt es da auch test haben die auch antworten drinne haben die da auch antworten für drinne moment wo sind die antworten
Zuordnung sind das hier die lösung lösung ok ok ich darf jetzt nicht gucken lösung lösung 1 sekunde sekunde das sind das sind lösung ne wo sind die lösung hier wie
Wie häh lösung ga 1 das ist doch ga 1 ich bin ich bin hochgradig verwirrt moment wir suchen da einfach jetzt danach
Was genau findet er da ga 1 handlungsschritt 1 ist das so ga lösung ga 1 ach moment die lösung sind direkt hier dahinter ok
Sekunde sekunde lösung ich gucke auch nicht ich gucke auch nicht weiter lösung ne häh ich blicks nicht ga 1 lösung ga 1 antworten zu c
Alter ok ich hab keine ahnung also relax critical information ich find noch nichtmal die lösung ok wir können handlungsschritt 1 suchen ok
Was auch immer es gibt keine es gibt keine lösung echt ich hab's über plattert erzählt mir nichts ich baitet mich ich hab's nicht über plattert
Also also das haben wir jetzt gelöst easy seite 21 ok chat ich glaube euch
Ne es hat doch überhaupt nichts damit zu tun seite 21 oder ist das die antwort ne
Sie baitet wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt die seite fertig wir machen jetzt die seite fertig also hier chat also das haben wir gelöst easy 100% sie schlagen für das
Netzwerk private ip adressen vor wie so noob style warum soll ich da private ip adressen vorschlagen einfach öffentlich routbares netz und
Irgend ein öffentliches slash 8 und gutes für den für den 15 jahre alten drucker ok also sie schlagen für das Netzwerk private ip adressen vor erklären sie dem Kunden den Unterschied zwischen öffentlichen und privaten ip adressen nennen sie hierbei auch die privaten adressbereiche
Ok die privaten adressbereiche die weiß ich die privaten adressbereiche sind 10.0.0 slash 8 192 16.0.0 slash 12 192 11.0.0 slash ne doch moment doch doch jaja glaub schon doch also das sind die privaten netzbereiche
Slash 12 ja relativ sicher der in der Mitte ist falsch was soll denn das sonst sein ok chat prediction ist es falsch moment moment moment wir stimmen jetzt ab
prediction prediction
so vorhersage starten slash 12 richtig ja nein jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wieviel wieviel bei uns im chat sich damit ausgehen wieviel nicht
ok sagen wir alles ist richtig ok das können wir uns auch sparen ja 12 slash 12 ist relativ sicher ok ip was ist das class b private ach moment ich darf jetzt noch nicht gucken die Umfrage ist noch nicht vorbei
ok ok wobei doch ich gucke jetzt einfach nach easy und dann wird es markiert als
ich noch gar nicht ich kann den noch gar nicht als ok markieren
mathe abi pence champ richtiger messages deleted irgendwelche franzosen nachrichten ok also wenn es jetzt doch falsch ist dann habt dann habt ihr euch alle krass
jibane lassen ich glaube man kann als mod nicht abstimmen oder wenn man das mod abstimmt könnte man der das so markieren wie man wie man will ok twitch auf jetzt mach mal hinne hier ach kann man ok ok also jetzt gucken wir nach
so private private ip adresse 16 00 slash 12 ich habe recht also prediction ist bei mir übrigens gerade verschwunden im chat es wäre sehr nett wenn ein mod die als stimmt markieren könnte
so also weiter im text also das hat das hat das haben wir das haben wir stimmt 100 prozent 100 prozent punkte also erklären sie dem unterschied na gut also der unterschied ist ganz einfach es gibt drei als privat definierte ip adresse
bereiche das bedeutet dass die im öffentlichen internet nicht geroutet werden dass sobald so eine ip eine route abkriegt sagen wir mal von der telekom oder von sonst was dass der das wegschmeißt wenn er richtig konfiguriert ist zumindest und eure fritzbox das schon gar nicht weiter routen sollte irgendwo anders hin
oder fritzbox macht er nicht umsonst nat am ausgang und schreibt das um zu eurer öffentlichen ip und merkt sich das in der tabelle dass es wieder zuordnen kann wenn es zurückkommt du kannst nicht weil du teil genommen hast ja vielleicht kann ich das ja markieren
das ergebnis wählen wählen sie das ergebnis richtig ja zack
also dann dann dann also wenn man wenn man das wurde routen aus außen vor lassen sollte könnte man einfach sagen dass private adresse nicht nicht im internet weitergeleitet werden oder nicht im internet
aber weitergeleitet werden trifft sie eigentlich ganz gut und dass dementsprechend ganz viele leute auf der welt die gleichen privaten adressen verwenden können ohne dass sie was voneinander wissen oder jemals jemals sehen
gut
quote war 1,02 ja gut ok ich glaube hier haben 100 prozenter punkte easy next also das hatten wir doch grad schon die haben wir doch hier schon
so was das hier jetzt nach gesprächen mit dem netzwerkadministrator des kunden haben sie die abgebildete übersicht der gewünschten netzstruktur erstellt planen sie anhand dieser übersicht die notwendigen netze wie ich habe die übersicht erstellt
warum hat der netzwerkadministrator nicht so eine übersicht wenn es doch der netzwerkadministrator ist was ist das für ein komischer netzwerkadministrator außerdem nehme ich das nicht ich nehme sowas nur als nasi schneiderman struktur
also andere anderweitig ist das nicht lesbar für mich also nach dem ok planen sie an dieser übersicht die notwendigen subnetze ein nasi schneiderman struktogramm beste hier diagramm
hier so eins ich war ich programmier nur noch so bevor ich auch nur eine zeile code schreiben das habt ihr oft genug im stream schon gesehen mache ich immer sowas ich kann gar nicht programmieren mehr ohne
so also was soll ich denn hier jetzt machen und danach mache ich noch einen uml mini cup also ok planen sie anhand dieser übersicht die notwendigen subnetze
ach nee müssen wir jetzt wirklich subnetting scheiß machen ok also das netz 192.168.33.0.24 ok das ist easy as fuck die machen dann slash 24 draus soll in 4 gleichgroße subnetze unter da habe ich keinen bock drauf
chat da habe ich keinen bock drauf jetzt überspringen das skippe ich jetzt das skippe ich jetzt ich darf das übrigens skippen ich darf das skippen weil wisst ihr was für ein teil ich in meiner abschlussprüfung gestrichen habe
ich habe in meiner abschlussprüfung subnetting und strukturierte verkabelung gestrichen und habe dafür den programmierteil gemacht ich war einer der wenigen die glaube ich den programmierteil gemacht haben und das easy kram hier gedenkst haben
das machen wir jetzt nicht da habe ich keinen bock drauf ist aber ist aber ist aber nicht schwer zumalzen slash 24 das besonders easy so ein mitarbeiter der IT abteilung hat eine skizze zu dem thema MAC adressen IP adressen im lagen gefunden klären sie ihn auf warum es sich bei dieser bei der skizze handelt das wüsste ich auch gerne was das für eine skizze ist
ja wo soll ich wissen was das für eine skizze ist ich habe sie ja nicht gemacht also MAC adresse lautet benötigt meine was ist das für eine frage meine MAC adresse aah aah jetzt jetzt verstehe ich jetzt ok meine güte die frage ist wieder geil gestellt jetzt habe ich es verstanden
jetzt habe ich es wiederいetzt jetzt habe ich WHOIS jaja things ap anfragen glaube ich soll das sein ne
Anfragen glaube ich soll das sein
Der chat wusste schon wieder, der chat wusste schon wieder
Was aber das diagramm ist ist ist schon ziemlich kacke
Ich meine normalerweise machst du für sowas also normalerweise machst du für sowas so ein diagramm. Kennt ihr, kennt ihr diese dinger?
Eins zwei normalerweise machst du da diese dinger
floop
floop floop. Kennt ihr das?
die dinger
Also die sind die sind die sind die für diese verzeitliche abläufe sind die eigentlich viel viel cooler
Sequenzdiagramm genau. Nee nee nee ich mein keine
Leute ich meine die die die die sorte von dieser zeichnung nicht dass man darin unter anderem auch einen handshake abbilden kann
Da kann sie alles mögliche drin abbilden
Ja ok abrequest möchte sie uns also wahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich möchten sie uns mit diesem diagramm sein das ist ein typisch ein typisch beschissen gestellte frage
Klären sie ihn auf worum es sich bei der skizze handelt ja
Also da würde ich sagen ich vermute mal
Das ist eine skizze wo uns irgendjemand erklären wollte anhand irgendwie einem sehr merkwürdig gezeichneten
Pfeil gedöns wie man
Die mac adresse zu einer gehörigen ip warum ip benötigt
ist moment moment moment das ist gar kein ab
das ist dhcp oder
Das ist keine ab das ist dhcp leute die haben ich die haben ich die haben ich gebaited
Oder
Was zum geier soll das sein
Also am am anfang hätte ich gesagt am anfang ist klar das soll ein abrequest sein
Ja am anfang ist klar das ist das ist das ist das ist ein abrequest, aber
Das ist ein abrequest
Aber
Aber am anfang hätte ich gesagt klar das ist das ist das ist ein abrequest, aber ich das ist so scheiße gemacht du weißt überhaupt nicht was der was
Was der will
Ob das hier ein switch ist weiß die auch noch einmal wahrscheinlich ja
Es könnte auch sein dass sie was von dhcp wissen wollen
Naja gut weil weil
Das da ist im prinzip ja
Was soll das sein
Der dhcp request doch dhcp kann schon eine spezifische dhcp also kannst du kannst ein lease erneuern aber
Who ist
Okay, okay, okay doch das ist ab das ist ab der typ der rechner der rechner will
Nee
Warum ist hier was gesucht? Ah ja doch okay der rechner sucht die mac adresse
Zu aber dann sagt er doch nicht benötigt
Der macht das ist das ist das was du in dem dhcp samt dhcp damps siehst oder immer da steht
Who has who has so da okay da sagt der sagt er braucht
Diese ip dann leitet das das switch weiter der der rechner kriegt
Der rechner kriegt sieht den abrequest
Und der antwortet dann who has tell ja doch das ist ab das ist kein dhcp das muss ab sein alles andere ergibt keinen sinn
Es ist aber schon echt beschissen gemalt haben wir da antworten irgendwie für
Also das ist das ghr 1 ne wir haben dazu keine antworten glaube ich das ist aber richtig das ist aber richtig beschissen gemacht
Okay also weiter gehts weiter gehts ihr kunde ein mittelständisches unternehmen möchte das telefonsystem der firmenzentrale auf voice
Oh nee da würde ich dem davon abraten oder ich würde es weitersuchen
Da würde ich das weitersuchen würde ich sagen kunde macht das mal schön alleine
Sie beraten den kunden eines allein schon das ist eine komplett grundsätzlich falsche falsche annahme
Ich würde den kunden nicht beraten was wyp angeht ich würde das mal weg
Erläutern sie dem standortleiter das ist für die fragestell natürlich enorm wichtig dass es das standortleiter ist
Der firma kurz das prinzip von voice over ip ja das wüsste ich ehrlich gesagt auch gern
Das wüsste ich ehrlich gesagt auch ich glaube es gibt keine sehr wohl versteht das muss ich skippen da muss ich passen also
Verstehe ich bis heute nicht
Okay die ihk ist wahrscheinlich damit einverstanden
Aber ich glaube das ist ein bisschen unbekannte
Ich glaube das ist ein bisschen unbekannte
Okay die ihk ist wahrscheinlich damit einverstanden dass man sagt
Sprachdaten werden über das bestehende ip netz weitergeleitet oder sowas
reicht wahrscheinlich
Und wenn du da noch reinschreibst dass du irgendwie spezielle voice codecs dafür verwendet werden um
Dann quasi analog zur digital konvert irgendwas rein dann sind die wahrscheinlich zufrieden damit
Okay was wollen sie jetzt wissen sie erstellen gemeinsam mit dem netzwerkadministrator eine übersicht über die geräte in einem voice
Was wollen die mit ihrem scheiß voice over ip
Sie haben bereits information zu den eigenschaften der geräten gesammelt
Ordnen sie diese mit feilen den geräten zu also
Vermittlung
Ach ich soll jetzt hier feile malen ne gut das kann ich ja schlecht schlecht
Ja aber das können wir uns überlegen also
Vermittlungsgerät zwischen voip und herkömmlichen telefonnetz
Software die pc zu einem voip endgeräten
Macht ok soft phone ist das da das da kann man da irgendwas reinschreiben
Nee ok das da gerät mit dem herkömmliche telefon im voip netz verwendet werden können
Voip gateway wollen sie da wahrscheinlich haben wobei moment herkömmliche geräte
Nee ja doch oder
Weiter ausschlußverfahren ja kprüfung ausschlußverfahren
Telefon das direkt an das lan angeschlossen wird
Voip telefon ok das ist easy das heißt easy die zwei sachen haben wir schon mal weg die zwei sachen haben wir schon mal weg
Telefonanlagen die voip
Telefonanlagen die voip endgeräte unterstützt das da
Das sind telefonanlagen die voip geräte unterstützt
So also im prinzip haben wir jetzt noch zur auswahl
Vermittlungsgerät zwischen voip und herkömmlichen telefonnetz
Ist das nicht das gleiche
Gerät mit dem herkömmlichen telefon im voip netz verwendet
Also eins vermittelungsgeräte vermittel zwischen voip und herkömmlichen telefonnetz
Ok dann muss das der gateway sein weil das ein vermittelungsgerät ist ok das muss der gateway sein
Und gerät mit dem herkömmliche telefon im voip netz verwendet werden können ist ein analog telefon adapter
Was auch immer
Das wird schon stimmen das wird schon kifke in 18 monat angestellt für hyper subscribtion
Was geht wir mal bald sind ihr kprüfung machen gerade so eine komische beispielprüfung ok
Ein mitarbeiter der service abteilung des kunden äußert bedenken gegenüber was haben die mit ihrem voip die ganze zeit
Da er gehörte das voip auf udp übertragen wird erklären sie den mitarbeiter warum udp für voice over ip verwendet wird
Wo wir wieder beim ursprünglichen thema sind was weiß ich denn auch was für voip gemacht wird
Ok aber für die ursprüngliche geschichte man kann sich das natürlich zusammen reiben auch wenn man gar keine ahnung hat
Also tcp versus udp du hast ja die geschichte dass du bei dem ein so eine art flusskontrolle beziehungsweise
Na wie heißt retry mechanismus drinne hast das brauchst du bei voip alles nicht also sprich ob pakete verloren gehen oder nicht
Ist vollkommen egal also was heißt ist vollkommen egal also du musst es nicht wissen ob pakete verloren gehen
Weil wenn du mitbekommst dass ein paket verloren gegangen ist es ist bei voip eh schon zu spät
Du kannst es ja schlecht nochmal neu schicken und es kommt dann eine sekunde später an und dann dann schneidet er ein paket rein
Mit deinen voice daten von vor einer sekunde das das das funktioniert nicht wenn du das nicht innerhalb von einem gewissen zeitfenster bekommst
Ist vorbei also die wollen wahrscheinlich hören dass udp weniger overhead hat als tcp was aber ehrlich gesagt
Zwar theoretisch so ist aber praktisch prinzip kein unterschied macht
Was denn sonst noch
Ja gut du brauchst kein retry du brauchst kein retry verfahren ja also das ist unsinnig bei bei voip in der theorie oder in der praxis auch man kann genauso gut über tcp machen
By the way das ist überhaupt kein problem also man muss das nicht über junipi machen
Was niedrigen overhead du brauchst die vorteile von tcp nicht
Was ist denn sonst was ist denn sonst die latenz macht eigentlich eventuell theoretisch könnte man sich da was zusammen reiben aber unterm strich macht es eigentlich keinen unterschied
Was ist was ist was ist sonst noch
Was sind sonst noch so die vorteile davon
Ich meine
Gut der das paket ist kleiner theoretisch
Das paket ist das paket ist ein bisschen kleiner oder ich glaube in udp header hat ein bisschen weniger sachen drinne als in tcp header
Also theoretisch ist das paket ein bisschen klar aber das haben wir eigentlich schon das haben wir das haben wir eigentlich schon abgehandelt mit weniger overhead ja
Ja also ich würde sagen du hast du hast du hast weniger overhead und du hast halt du brauchst halt die ganzen vorzüge von tcp in dem fall nicht
Du brauchst kein handshake machen und sonstige dinge du kannst die dinge einfach raushauen und und feiern forget und gut ist
Was halt gut passt für weib weil bei weib bringt es dir nichts wenn du eine sekunde später merkt hohen paket ist nicht angekommen und dann
Request ist du es neu bis dahin ist es eh schon abgespielt
Ja
Guck mal samstag nachmittag hat hier wieder
Ja das stimmt wobei das jetzt auch
Da zumindest muss ich dann nichts damit beschäftigen zu versuchen die pakete nochmal neu zu übertragen das ist tatsächlich nicht nicht verkehrt
Genau du kannst nämlich das ist das ist ein guter punkt du kannst nämlich bei
Bei weib ziemlich auf paketverlust scheißen sofern auch genug pakete ankommen
Also klingt jetzt erstmal widersprüchlich aber das ist halt das was ich am anfang gesagt habe es bringt halt nichts ein paket neu anzufragen bei weib
Wenn du es eine sekunde später dann paket bekommst dann hast du es ja schon abgespielt
Und was brauchst du ein paket wenn du wenn du die wenn du quasi schon tec wenn du die sprache schon abgespielt hast und es einen kleinen ruckler gab
Wozu brauchst du das paket dann eine sekunde später wenn es dann ankommt also das ja
Ok weiter jetzt also aus sicherheitsgründen soll der komplette weib datenverkehr in einem separaten wlan übertragen werden oder streichen sie konkret was korrekten aussagen
Bezüglich bezüglichen wie lans das erste stimmt oder war das nur port security autentifizierung
Nee ich glaube dass dort ein skew ist ist dort ist das ich glaube das ist wähler
Boar jetzt wollte es ist aber wissen jetzt jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen ok
Wie lang ok also ein wie lang bildet eine broadcast domäne nicht zwangsläufig wlan ist dann ist quasi
Ein eigener switch wenn du so willst warte mal warte mal lass mal lass mal kurz lass lass mal kurz lass mal kurz in mich gehen
Was war noch mal der unterschied broadcast ist was auf broadcast ist ja was auf ip ebene ok also das ist auf jeden fall falsch
Das ist auf jeden fall falsch also wenn du das ist ja quasi layer 2 oder quasi wenn du wenn du alles in ein wlan packst dann kann sich
Wobei moment fack man wie lange der scheiß ist so lange her ich würde fast sagen das stimmt beides nee das ist also broadcast
Wie hatten das mit broadcast noch mal funktioniert broadcast geht an die geht an den netz adress aber du musstest doch bei einem broadcast musstest du nicht auch noch
Im internet frame irgendwas setzen dass es ein broadcast ist musste man da nicht noch irgendwas setzen oder bringe ich das jetzt irgendwie durcheinander
Ich habe keine ahnung
Wir lesen das wikipedia dazu das wlan tag musst du setzen genau das wlan tag musst du im ethernet frame setzen sowas ist das
Fuck
Das ist der dhcp kram das habe ich jetzt durchgebracht
Fuck alter ok dann dann ist das im prinzip falsch ich meine ich kann in ein wlan total viele unterschiedliche ip netze reinpacken
Und das hat die broadcast um ihn hat damit im wlan nichts zu tun ich kann doch in ein wlan kann ich doch 50 50 netze reinpacken das hat doch damit überhaupt nichts zu tun ip technisch
Podcast um ihn ist recht warum warum ist das richtig
Erst durch die unterteilung in wlans oder durch den einsatz von routern ja warum
Aber moment denke denke ich das jetzt falsch ich glaube ich weiß was die meinen ich glaube ich weiß was die meinen
Wenn du quasi ein wlan machst und darin rechner reinpackst in einem netz und du nimmst ein zweites wlan und packst da rechner in einem anderen netz oder meinetwegen auch im gleichen netz rein
Dass das die anderen dann nicht sehen weil weil ansonsten stimmt das doch eigentlich net weil mal angenommen ich habe jetzt im gleichen wlan 20 unterschiedliche netze das ist doch vollkommen egal da grenzt das wlan doch nichts
Ja genau du kannst du kannst in zwei verschiedenen wlan kannst du zweimal das gleiche netz verwenden das ist richtig ja gut wenn ich so meine dann ergibt das sinn ja
So und schätzt sind wir uns jetzt eigentlich ob das gilt oder oder nicht also ich meine das ist ja das sollte eigentlich falsch sein oder oder doch ich habe keine ahnung
Geiler kollision wir sind ja 2021 ihk please
Falsch okay okay wir sind falscher chat sagen wir sind falsch und der chat der ist aber sowas prinzipiell immer richtig also weiter zur ordnung zu einem wlan kann portweise im switch konfiguriert werden
Ja kannst du machen also je nachdem wie man den switch einrichtet aber du kannst sagen wenn ungeteckter traffic reinkommt dann macht damit was
Das kannst du machen ja und beim rausgehen aus dem port wieder entfernen was ist ein wlan einen flack im ethernet frame wo eine id drinne steht anhand dessen das switch dann zuordnen kann welche rechner sich im gleichen virtuellen switch quasi befinden
Ein wlan ist im prinzip ein virtueller switch wenn du es so willst oder ein wlan bildet eine broadcast domäne um es fall zu sagen mit ak worten
Also im prinzip sind wlans ziemlich einfach implementiert irgendwo hier hier so sieht ein normaler ethernet frame aus und irgendwo da ist hast du 4 bytes für den wlan tag
Wlans kann man doch fast mit subnetzen vergleichen ne kann man nicht
Du kannst in einem wlan ohne probleme 50 verschiedene subnetze haben
Ein wlan ist im prinzip wenn du deinen switch durchschneidest du machst aus einem switch 2 oder halt virtuelle switche mit intern wie auch immer du kannst da ganz viel abgedrehte sachen machen
Genau wlans sind software switches das triffts eigentlich ganz gut
Du kannst natürlich noch ein bisschen abgedrehte sachen machen dass du zum beispiel sagst hey ich erlaub nur geteckten ich erlaub nur ungeteckten traffic wenn ungeteckter traffic ist dann kommt es automatisch in den default wlan ist es allerdings geteckt
Und in diesem wlan sind auf diesem switchport wlan 5 6 7 8 erlaubt und sowas in der richtung aber im prinzip ist es du schneidest einfach deinen switch durch du nimmst deinen switch schneidest in 3 teile
Also weiter in wlans müssen private ip adressen verwendet werden müssen nicht das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun dynamische zuordnungen zu wlans keine hand der mac adressen
Was das geht glaube ich macht man sowas ich glaube das geht wir haben das mal gemacht ich kann mich noch dran erinnern wir hatten mal wir hatten mal
Bei irgendwelchen load balancern kam dann anhand der anhand der ziel mac oder irgendwas ganz merkwürdig haben wir da was gemacht aber macht das wirklich jemand also das geht
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich nicht häufig benutzt oder
Ja doch wobei hey das ist gar nicht so unsinnig du könntest zum beispiel sagen du könntest zum beispiel sagen dein dein dein voip telefon
Dein voip telefon kommt kommt in standardmäßig in andere spieler als dein desktop
Dafür ist das glaube ich ganz praktisch doch ok das ergibt das ergibt das ergibt doch sinn ja
Dann ist das was andere das ist was anderes was ich meinte was wir mit unsere load balancern gemacht haben aber ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie das heißt wir haben mal irgendwas mit unsere load balancern gemacht dass wir
Traffic anhand irgendeiner mac adresse dann verteilt haben fragt mich nicht mehr wie das was das was das genau war ganz abgedrehter kram
Ok also bei vilans die mehrere switch überspannen werden zwischen den switches vilan text verwendet
Ja genau das ist richtig sobald sobald das den switch verlässt werden die vilan text in der regel wieder entfernt
Es sei dann es ist halt auf der anderen seite was was das weiterverarbeitet aber in der regel sind die sind sind die dinger getackt weil der andere switch auch wissen muss was sache ist
Ja also das würde ich schon sagen das richtig vilans ok das ist das ist die das ist das ist der idiotentest da unten
So der kunde interessiert sich dafür wie viel verschiedene vilans prinzipiell konfiguriert werden können eine einschränkung bringt die vilan das haben wir uns ja gerade angefuckt sie besteht aus 12 bits
Also 4096 muss glaube ich gar nicht da muss ich glaube ich gar nicht ausrechnen also in der regel früher war es immer 4096 wo es
Wo dann immer ein limit war wo es dir dann auch angezeigt hat so nach dem motto wenn du 4050 machen wolltest oh ne geht nicht
Obbei ich glaube gibt es da nicht mittlerweile irgendwie ein paar hex das sogar mehr geben kann oder ist es egal wie die dinger heißen
VX vilan ja das kann sein weil ich bilde mir auch ein dass ich jetzt schon öfters gesehen habe dass man da dass man da mehr machen kann
Gut wie ich habe sie hier gezeigt hier ist einfach nur platz im frame für zwölf bits also 4096 hier kannst du einfach hinschreiben
2 hoch 2 hoch zwölf gleich 4096 weiß jemand ob ich wirklich eins bis 4096 nehmen muss oder ob ich oder ob ich auch
Ne ich muss eins bis 4096 nehmen zumindest zumindest mit der klassischen variante ich konnte ich kann jetzt beispielsweise nicht 50.000 nehmen aber
Ne ne das funktioniert nicht okay next oh chat siehste tibetan hat uns die irk sind 4096 minus 2 weil weil null weil null nicht
Und 4095 nicht ich hatte die irk prüfung nicht mal so kompliziert in erinnerung aber wahrscheinlich wusste ich das damals alles auswendig
Und heute habe ich das alles vergessen ich sehe ich da xml sehe ich da sehe ich da xml boah ne oder bloß nicht
Könnte ich nicht vilans nästen also quasi einen ethernet frame in einen weiteren einpacken das kannst du theoretisch machen mir ist
Allerdings nichts bekannt was das so out of the box unterstützt ich meine das ist eine reine software geschichte das kannst du sicherlich
Machen in irgendeine art und weise aber ja das habe ich so noch nicht gesehen also ich meine mit dem layer 2 vpn ist es ja
Im prinzip nichts anderes wenn du layer 2 vpn machst passiert ja genau das du baust du baust den vpn auf übers internet und darin verschickst
Du dann eingepackt deine ethernet frames also ja du kannst das nästen aber wie auch immer so was macht gehen tut das also ok jetzt
Kommt jetzt kommt ganz die hardcore xml variante die folgende an teilen sind xml script xml script
Alter eines gängigen cm systems ordnen sie die erläuterung den entsprechenden xml text zu ach du scheiße
Der hans kaiser ist da ok also xml nateil kunden xml was
Ah ok ok ok xml nateil kunden xml ist das hier element typ mit einer beliebigen zeichenkette als inhalt
Moment das ist das schema oder ist das ein schema ist das ein schema so was in der richtung keine ahnung was ein dtd ist
Was ist ein dtd dtd das ist eine art schema oder ok dann muss element typ auf jeden fall was sein in hier drinnen und nicht hier drinnen
Also element typ mit einer beliebigen zeichenkette als inhalt ist das da das da element mit beliebigen element inhalt
Da sieht man schon mal wieder wie zurückgeblieben xml ist ist dann wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich das da und dann haben wir doch element typ mit beliebiger wiederholung
Ne moment wait a minute cac wait dann muss ja das eigentlich das da sein ausschlussverfahren ist 5 das da weil weil element mit beliebigen inhalt würde ich sagen ist ist
ist ist ne moment moment a moment zeichenkette war das erste wo wir sekunde sekunde zeichenkette ne ne ich hab mich ver ich hab mich ich hab mich ich hab mich verlesen
Element mit beliebigen inhalt große scheiße element mit beliebigen inhalt ist ist dann doch das ne ich hab keine ahnung also mit den wiederholungen ist das da da bin ich mir relativ sicher
also element mit beliebiger wiederholung ist ist ist das da ne da ist irgendwas doppelt und irgendwas mit plus und was auch immer das heißt das pummel pimpe
dankeschön für 3 monate so das wiederholung so dann haben wir jetzt nur die 2 zur auswahl mit beliebiger zeichenkette als inhalt und mit beliebigen element inhalt
so zeichenkette sieht hier nach aus genau das ist zeichenkette 3 das ist 3 und beliebigen element inhalt nämlich elemente name straße wohner telefonnummer ist dann das hier
stimmts ich hoffe mal 11 monat dankeschön für die big brain subscription ok sowieso wird das sein weiter gehts element mit daten element mit daten ja das da moment das muss ich das muss ich jetzt erstmal
das ist auch ein element mit daten und das ist auch ein element mit daten ok wiederholungs element das hier ist ein wiederholungs element dann ist das hier ein element mit daten
wohnort liegt dann ist ein kommentar kommentar das da ist ein kommentar das da kennzeichnung der datei als xml datei ist das da verweis auf eine externe dtd datei ist das da
leute wir haben es geschafft wir haben es geschafft und jetzt xml weiter weiter für die durchführung eines software projektes hatte ich guck mal kurz chat muss mich
ein bisschen ein bisschen auf bisschen abrengen über über xml warum fragt man so einen crap überhaupt noch in der abschlussprüfung leute mal frage an euch die prüfungsvorbereitung machen habt ihr euch auch mit xml beschäftigt für so dumme fragen ja ist xml nicht eine auszeichnung ja da logik ist ja da nicht drinne so wirklich ich wusste das auch nicht dass es so eine art schema gibt aber
das habe ich jetzt gerade gelernt aus der iak prüfung übermorgen ist prüfung das kann ich nicht glaube ich nicht dass ich das aus dem stehgreif irgendwas auf die reihe kriege da muss man bestimmt binary trees inverten und sowas so
also für die für die durchführung eines software projektes hat der kunde alle vorgänge in einem plan erfasst also allein schon allein schon allein schon das hier ist ja mal prinzipiell falsch das hat er bestimmt nicht gemacht das wäre das glaube ich nicht dass er das cheesy pro dankeschön für die für den sub ok er möchte diesen plan
wir echt ein fucking ein voll damit nein das mache ich nicht chat ich weigere mich das mache ich nicht das mache ich nicht das könnt ihr vergessen ich werde hier kein gantia kram mal garantiert nicht das letzte mal dass ich den gantia kram gemacht habe war in meiner abschluss war in meiner abschluss dokumentation das mache ich nicht nein das meine ich vergesse
ich stelle sie also einen netzplan und ein gantia kram kennzeichen den kritischen fad im netzplan auch ach du nein das mache ich nicht das mache ich nicht fad früheste anfangszeitpunkt fad früheste endzeitpunkt satz späteste anfangszeit
was für eine ausgeburt der hölle ist das denn da
Leute soll ich euch mal wollt ihr mal mein blut werden facts ich zeige euch mal geile facts hat also damit überhaupt nichts zu tun
wusstet ihr dass alle ein window emoji haben außer microsoft alle haben den window emoji nur microsoft nicht
wieder was gelernt ja
ja alle apple google samsung whatsapp twitter microsoft nicht und ich habe mir jetzt überlegt warum nicht warum nicht ich glaube die wollten vorbeugen dass es probleme in windows gibt weil es
einen character gibt der in irgendeiner tabelle window heißt das ist bestimmt dass die haben bestimmt schiss dass windows kaputt geht wenn es wenn es sowas gibt
ja siehst du doch hier was meinst du warum das bei mir hinten ist ich habe ein windows chrome die haben keins die haben keins alle anderen haben eins
nur mal so nebenbei werden wir keine prüfe gucken also weiter das mache ich jetzt nicht leute ich habe ich habe keine ahnung was das hier überhaupt ist
ich habe das sicherlich irgendwann mal gewusst aber ich weiß es nicht mehr ich habe prinzipiell alle bvl sachen im instant vergessen ich habe keine ahnung
also das kann ich nicht da wäre ich durchgefallen steht doch da was das ist ja ok es muss ein netz es muss es muss ein netzplan sein weil es ist definitiv kein gantt diagramm
das mache ich nicht leute vergesst das ist noch nicht der bvl teil nee nee iiii jetzt geht der extra
bvl teil nee nee iiii jetzt wird er immer schlimmer was kommt denn jetzt noch
was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder
stellen sie den ablauf auftragsabwägung form eines ereignisgesteuerten prozess was für ein teil
übertragen sie dafür den richtigen text ach du scheiße ich hätte keine ahnung ich hätte wirklich ich hätte absolut keinen plasten
ach du scheiße was ist denn das das sieht aus wie visio für arme
leute das kann ich nicht ich ernsthaft ich kann das nicht ich wüsste nicht was ich da machen soll
fügen sie auch die notwendigen opera was was soll ich da überhaupt machen übertragen sie dafür den richtigen text in die leeren symbole
funktion ereignis dateninformation ich weiß auch nicht mal was ich was die von mir wollen bei
der iak jetzt was was wollen die überhaupt funktionen ereignisse dateninformation dokument oder organisation
fügen sie auch die ok leute wir sind im daily scrum da sind wir noch genau richtig also ich hab absolut keine ahnung
nee ich will das gar nicht können ich überspringen das jetzt ich geb das ich geb das das das wäre beide die auf die aufgabe die ich gestrichen hätte
ok also weiter übrigens übrigens ich ich der titel wir sind bei kern bei ihr habt das ihr habt das richtig gelesen wir sind bei kernqualifikationen
also wenn ihr euch fahr informatik system integration nennen wollt dann solltet ihr das besser können das ist eine kernqualifikation für euch
so also weiter sie zeigen dem kunden die definition für ein qualitätsmanagement system als würde ich sowas machen und erläutern ihm das ein bestimmter aufbau
seiner organisation zu den grundbausteinen eines solchen system gehört zur anschauung haben sie die iak hat echt einen dachschaden oder
zur anschauung haben sie ein diagramm entwickelt beschriften sie nein was sie mir die unterstellen mir hier immer dinger die ich nie im leben machen würde
zur anschauung haben sie ein diagramm entwickelt beschriften sie dieses diagramm mit den entsprechenden bezeichnungen 5 punkte definition qualitäts dien iso 9000
oh fuck meine güte system für die festlegung der qualitätspolitik und von qualitätszielen sowie zum erreichen der ziele allein schon dieser satt sagt doch was das für einen schwachsinn ist oder
ablauforganisation qualitätspolitik aufbauressourcenmanagementrahmenbeding also ich soll jetzt einen dieser begriffe in jeweils ein hier dieser kässtchen schmeißen oder
fack ich hab keine ahnung ok also also genau ablauf das aufbau das rahmenbedingungen oben drüber oder rahmenbedingungen und in die qualitätspolitik
obendrüber qualitätspolitik obendrüber rahmenbedingungen dahin und was bleibt noch und ressourcenmanagement da
rahmenbedingungen ganz und ach scheiß drauf ach du scheiß es geht ja noch weiter was ist das denn jetzt schon wieder was für ein ding
was für ein ding
was ist das was ist das ein was für ein ding
ein f-kumpen ein f-kumpen alter gatschi bass f-kumpen
fack ein qualitätsmanagementsystem ist das efqm modell european foundation for quality management model welches auf dem total quality management passiert ein wichtiger aspekt ist der pdca zyklus
so voll teufel ist das der pdca zyklus der in unanständiger produkt
so life cycle ding oder so ich hab absolut keinen platzen schimmer was das ist ich hab das noch nie in meinem leben gesehen
was ist denn der pdca zyklus ey okay ich weiß man darf nicht der deming kreis oder das demingrad oder auch schiewart cycle
fack alter das macht mich fertig also ich bin ich bin nicht geboren für bwl kram ehrlich plan do check act warum kann man das da nicht einfach reinschreiben
dann wüsste man wenigstens was es ist plan do check act fack das buch darf man nicht mal verwenden oder in dem buch steht so ein kack drin
boah fack ey meine güte alles okay wieder wieder wieder beruhigen beruhigen ich bin nicht big brain genug dafür na ein mitarbeiter papp
fack die wollen es wissen die wollen es ernsthaft wissen jetzt kommt auch noch papp ich fass es nicht jetzt kommt noch ein papp hinten dran ein mitarbeiter des teams an ein program ablauf das macht kein mensch
das macht kein mensch ey wobei das stimmt nicht das machen die bei uns wirklich leute jetzt wo ich das sehe das kenne ich sogar doch doch das machen wirklich leute
das machen wirklich leute wir haben wir haben bei uns auch so prozessdesign leute die machen den ganzen tag sowas könnt ihr euch das vorstellen
könnt ihr euch wirklich vorstellen ihr sitzt den ganzen tag und macht sowas kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen aber es gibt es
ja also ein mitarbeiter des teams hat ein program ablauf und analysieren sie den papp und prüfen sie ob da program ablauf im sinne des refactorings verbessert oder vereinfacht werden kann
um die performance zu optimieren hat der entwicklungsleiter dich vorbeigemacht das nur drei verzweigungen
das ist ja eine geile regel mehr als drei ifs das funktioniert nicht performance zu schlecht
start hole drei rechnungsnummer aus der datenbank speichern variabler ok ok leute leute das macht bei uns niemand
also ich kenne keinen der also bei uns ich habe noch nie gesehen dass einer für irgendwie sowas in seinem programm sowas in dieser art und weise malt
ich kenne das gleiche nicht für ich habe mich übrigens gerade vertan was erzählen aber bei uns sitzen ganz nach leute rum und machen sowas
es gibt was sehr ähnliches für allgemeinen prozess für prozessabläufe das sieht genauso aus
das sieht genauso aus da steht dann sowas drinne wie first level nimm ticket an nächster schritt ist ticket klassifiziert hoch
hoch fragezeichen wenn ja direkt weiterleiten und sowas in der richtung aber das ist wieder was anderes bpmn ja ich glaube schon
ich glaube ich glaube das mein ja genau genau das meine ich das meint das habe ich gerade verwechselt das habe ich verwechselt aber nicht aber nicht mit dem schieffahrts cycle
ok also das ist ok das ist das ist eine programmieraufgabe die müsste mir eigentlich liegen
also hole 3 rechnungsnummer aus datenbank speichel in variable r1 r2 und r3 typ ganzzahl
also eine rechnungsnummer klingt erstmal sinnvoll aber ganz ehrlich ich würde eine rechnungsnummer nicht als int machen sondern eher als string
weil du willst in deiner rechnungsnummer eventuell nicht nur nummern haben so doofs klingt du willst eine rechnungs id eher haben aber egal
es ist schonmal ein int alles klar ok also wenn r1 kleine r2
was ist denn das für ein beschissenes unsinniges programm egal
kleinste nummer r1 und größte nummer was was so
what is happening man kann einfach das ist ohne scheiß leute sowas in code zu sehen hätte ich schon 30 mal gecheckt als gegenüber diesem diagramm
r1 kleiner r2 ja r2 kleiner r3 ja ausgabe kleinste nummer r1 und größte nummer r3
moment gibt es fehler in diesem diagramm oder geht es nur um die performanceoptimierung
ok also das funktioniert prinzipiell ja
nein kleinste meine gute was ja man könnte man könnte wahrscheinlich sich ein paar checks sparen denke ich mal weil wenn ich gecheckt habe ob
da bin ich gerade zu low brain für ich könnte wahrscheinlich hier hier zurück schon gehen ein research einbauen
ausgabe kleinste nummer r3 also das ist ja mal wirklich das ist ok leute das ist mit da kann ich mich gerade nicht richtig rein denken
also man kann garantiert hier irgendwelche sachen abkürzen
und ich darf wahrscheinlich auch nicht was weitere variablen dürfen aber ich darf mir das ergebnis hier von merken quasi
ach moment ich darf mir das ergebnis merken ok ich darf mir das ergebnis merken
ich darf mir das r1 r3 so ich könnte ich könnte das abkürzen ich könnte das abkürzen also das hier könnte ich machen so nein das hier bräuchte ich da nicht
weil hier unten check ich ja im prinzip noch mal das gleiche ne also könnte ich hier hier könnte ich eigentlich ne doch hier könnte ich zurück
hier könnte ich zurück gehen oder sehe ich das richtig also den könnte ich rausschmeißen oder
weil das hier check genau das gleiche wie das hier das heißt wenn ich hier dahin zurück gehe ist schon mal müsste müsste eigentlich passen
das heißt ich kann mir diesen ganzen diesen ganzen strang kann ich mir sparen
ne moment doch ich kann mir den kompletten strang hier sparen ne das da dieses komplette ding kann ich mir sparen
das komplette ding kann ich mir sparen hier oder und dann könnte ich das hier runter schieben den da hier dazwischen machen
ne das ist nein ne dann ach ist mir zu blöd ich überlasse das ich überlasse das bei dem massive brayton chat
aber das ist ja das ist ja echt anspruchsvoll hier was sie von einem wollen okay geht weiter mit kernqualifikation
übrigens heute ausrufezeiten stimmt nicht wirklich aber wir machen sowas ähnliches
die anbindung weiterer gebäude an das ethernet der firma soll geplant werden
die folgende skizze zeigt die entfernung in die geforderte übertragungsgeschwindigkeit zwischen den geräten
schlagen sie eine sinnvolle verkabelung vor und tragen sie die kabel entsprechende tabelle ein
ich soll ach du scheiß soll ich wissen für welche kabel technologie welche länge das weiß ich doch aus dem kopf
okay also zeigen wir mal das kriegen wir das kriegen wir raus das kriegen wir raus easy easy easy kriegen wir raus
also hier dazwischen kannst du stinknormale kupferkabel nehmen so alles was es theoretisch sogar beim aldi gibt gar kein problem
oder was gibt es eine auswahl an kabeltypen
so 10g 285 meter da würde sich tatsächlich ein glasfaserkabel anbieten
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht aus dem kopf ob man 285 meter mit irgendwie einem krass abgeschirrten kupferkabel machen kann
also ich hab noch im hinterkopf das eigentlich bei 100 meter immer schluss ist ich weiß aber nicht wie das bei neueren sachen aussieht
genau 100 habe ich auch im kopf dass das schluss ist so also hier würde ich ein glasfaserkabel nehmen außerdem ist es 10g das wird sich hier anbieten
welchen glasfaser typ kann ich ehrlich gesagt aus dem kopf nicht sagen
ne sf4 plus ist das modul net was für ein kabel sf4 plus ist der anschluss das modul stecker
im standard ist bei alle möglichen kupferdinger bei 100 meter immer schluss bei 10g keine ahnung
bei 10g brauchst du da wahrscheinlich ein mit diamanten verstärktes kabel oder so
so aber das passt ja eigentlich wir sind hier alle 40 meter 30 15 20
hier kannst du stinknormale kupferkabel nehmen hier würdest du glasfaserkabel nehmen
und hier würde ich wieder ein kupferkabel nehmen
hier 3450 meter eindeutig sattelit
ne hier würde ich auch ein glasfaserkabel nehmen allerdings weiß ich aus dem kopf die unterschiede nicht
es gibt 2 grundsätzlich unterschiedliche dinger wo du das eine nimmst du für super lange dinger und das andere nimmst du für kürzere
single mode und multimode genau
single mode geht länger oder genau
single ja oder genau single mode lang und teuer multimode kurz und günstig
genau da nehmen wir hier den multimode glasfaser und hier nehmen wir den single mode glasfaser
und hier nehmen wir natürlich nochmal das kupferkabel ok
ja ich glaube da haben wir ich glaube da liegen wir richtig mit
in der mitte reicht kupfer naja für 285 meter eigentlich nett
ich weiß nicht ob es in irgendeinem standard gibt wo drinnen steht dass es ein 10g kupferkabel gibt was 285 meter packt keine ahnung
aber ich würde sagen so aus dem stegreifen ne gibt es nicht
im nebengebäude selbst kannst du natürlich kupfer nehmen das ist klar das reicht 15 meter ist kein ding
ich glaube das passt was wir hier gemacht haben
unterstützung des kunden im bereich marketing jetzt wollen sie es wieder wissen
was so und ne ne ne ne ne ne das mache ich nicht das mache ich nicht das mache ich nicht
das da weiger ich mich das mache ich nicht dass das also
logsoft ja die sollen selbst logsoften
das im jahr 2013 auf den markt gebrachte logistikprogramm logsoft weist folgenden lebenszyklus auf
was wollen die überhaupt folgen in welcher lebenszyklusphase befindet sich das dargestellte produkt im jahr 2017
kein schimmer logsoft euch selbst
die produkte des kunden werden im portfolio der boston consulting group abgeb
sag mal sind die marketingleute alle irgendwie geistig zurück geblieben oder was ist das hier
kann doch nicht sein was ist das für
was zum teufel ist das das ist ein hund das ist ne kuh und
sind die nicht mehr bei tros sind die nicht mehr ganz dicht alle
die produkte des kunden wurden im portfolio
was das was ist das überhaupt was bin ich sehend was
in der darstellung fällt lediglich das logistikprogramm logsoft
ja so ein mist aber auch da muss es wohl weiter fehlen
was ist denn jetzt die frage dabei was genau ist hier die aufgabe überhaupt
was ist denn die aufgabe überhaupt dass ich sage wo logsoft hin muss oder was
da wo noch nix drin steht oder ich habe keine ahnung ich habe ernsthaft absolut keinen blassen schimmer
das ist die lösung da sind aber nicht die lösung zu unseren aufgaben das sind auch andere lösungen
boah ok leute genug das das war mir jetzt das war mir jetzt zu viel
meine güte eh hui hui hui hui hui hui hui hui hui hui
was ist denn logsoft gibt es das überhaupt
doch soviel oh das ist aber gut besuchte seite
Willst du mal 2018, ne ich kann also auch nicht off stream, off stream brauche ich das nicht,
ne.
Man kann es sich ja leider nicht im stream angucken, ok leute es ist 21.24, wir gucken
uns jetzt noch ein video an, eigentlich wollte ich mir mit euch ein paar videos angucken
und ich will mir den ganzen tag schon den neuen weltrekord angucken für, was data center
smoking power supply, ne das will ich mir nicht den ganzen tag angucken, aber ich will
jetzt mal sehen, ist das von ovh oder was ist das hier?
Oh, oh monka smoke, da sieht man aber gut wie der abzug hier ist, wie mehr geht nicht
oder was, oh was ist jetzt los, da kommt die polizei gerade oder was, alarm, alarm, warum
blitzt das so, ah das ist das man wahrscheinlich findet wo es brennt oder, oh, oh, ach wisst
ihr was das war, man soll jetzt, das ist bitte verlassen sie jetzt den raum, das ist Achtung,
Achtung bitte verlassen sie jetzt den raum, raus leute, raus leute, geht raus und jetzt
gleich geht die löschanlage an ist das, die hätten sie mal bei ovh sowas gehabt, jetzt
siehts ja gar nichts mehr, das war wirklich smoke, guck mal die rechner laufen doch easy,
diese wapen nation bestimmt äußerst gesund hier zu wapen nation, ok wisst ihr was, es
hätte wahrscheinlich schon was gebracht, man hätte einfach den strom abgestellt ne,
wäre hier einfach der strom aus, hätte man einfach den strom abgestellt, hätte wahrscheinlich
gereicht, wie schnell, lass mal, komm mal rauch, rauch, rauch, rauch, jetzt checkts
das noch nicht, das braucht ne ganze weile bis bis die sensoren das checken, dass es
da raucht, jetzt hats, jetzt hats gecheckt, ok, ne, wo davon sperrt kunden dns port,
ok das gucken wir uns jetzt an, press f hier, rip, leute wer es noch nicht mitgekriegt hat,
unser großer vor lacher ist gestorben am 28 april, ich hab jetzt auch im wikipedia eintrag
gelesen was sache ist, also er hatte wohl diabetes und äh hatte ne operation und hat sich davor
nicht nicht wieder erholt, ok auf gehts, huge quali, bessere quali geht nicht leute, easy
brunch, automatic merch, naja, automatic merch, naja gut, egal ich lass ihn jetzt an, oh man
page ist großer fehler bei git, ey die liga sind nicht in windings aber man versteht sie
nicht, das stimmt, oh moment leute ist da chat im weg, ist da chat im weg, ich mach
den chat weg, seh kunde, chat und fuß die katz auch weg, ich muss das mal kurz umbenennen,
äh in, wie benennt man den kram um, katze, ok ich machs noch mal, chunkler, chunkler,
ne das sind nicht, die sind nicht in windings aber man versteht sie halt null, man versteht
sie halt null, das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt auch, das stimmt auch, das stimmt
auch, ey das ist ohne scheiß, ich muss euch die man page zeigen von git push, nur das
ihr seht das stimmt was der typ sagt, ne, hier das ist die man page, das ist die man
page von git push und die erklärung ist schon mal wieder absolut hängen geblieben, update
remote revs using local revs while sending objects necessary to complete the given revs,
alles klar oder, vollkommen logisch was git push macht jetzt nachdem ihr das gelesen
habt und das nächste ist auch sehr vertrauenserweckend, you can make interesting things happen to
a repository every time you push into it, also gerade damit hat er wirklich recht, das ist
echt, also ich weiß nicht warum es immer noch so beschissen geschrieben ist wie früher,
ja upstream remote revs, genau, das ist echt ein geiler Ton, das ist echt ein geiler Ton,
ich seh nix mehr auf einem Auge, naja, die Dinger sind seit Anfang an schon so kacke,
so schlimm ist es nicht, so schlimm ist es nicht, so schlimm ist es auch nicht, man kommt
da relativ schnell rein, ne, ne, ne, das ist, das kann eigentlich nicht passieren,
das ist okay, das hatte ich auch schon, als ich paar reposachen fixen muss und ihr wisst,
ich verdiene mein Geld mit reposachen fixen.
Das Leute, schreibt euch davon was ab, merkt euch das, die Krankenversicherung haftet nicht
für GIT Schäden, Gott hab ihn selig, ja da muss ich da muss ich widersprechen GIT ist trotzdem das
beste ich bin GIT Fan
das ist gut, der Spruch ist gut, das muss ich mir merken,
die zweite Hälfte war nicht so lustig, aber die erste Hälfte war gut, so Leute und das Video will
ich mir eigentlich schon den ganzen Tag angucken, ich hab es mir extra gespeichert, den aktuellen
Breath of the Wild Any% Rekord, ich hab es mir extra gespeichert, wollte es mir heute Abend mit euch im
Stream angucken, wir haben jetzt genau noch, es geht 25 Minuten, wir haben genau 25 Minuten Zeit,
wie das Video passt, exzellent, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe lange keinen Breath of
the Wild Any% Speedrun mehr geguckt, die die ich gehückt hab waren alle noch eine ganze Ecke
langsam, mal 25 Minuten, das heißt ich vermute mal da werden ein paar sehr abgedrehte Sachen
passieren, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, ich kann den Chat wieder anmachen stimmt, Katze und Chat
so, jetzt aber 25 Minuten beriesen lassen, Spielruns, ja gut das Intro können wir übersp- ach komm ich lasse
einfach laufen, ich lasse einfach laufen, das Intro geht ja, Breath of the Wild Intro geht ja zum
Glück plus 30 Sekunden oder so, bisschen leise, ist das französisch
ja das ist französisch, spielen die das absichtlich auf französisch, weil der Text schneller läuft?
ich glaube ich kann noch einen Ticken lauter machen oder? Tablet Chica, alles klar
so, jetzt passt es glaube ich, ab jetzt ist es gut Lautstärke
was? was? was? ah ok einmal durch den Boden kletschen
was? man kann da rausklippen? ok das wusste ich nicht ok ich sehe schon, dass das wird
absolut nichts mit dem zu tun haben, was ich das letzte mal für den Anyperson Speedrun
geguckt habe, man kann da rausklitschen aus der Starthöhle, ok normalerweise erfriert
man doch an der Stelle, wahrscheinlich kann man das auch klitschen, dass man nicht erfriert
wieder unterbrechen, lass uns mal weiter, nackig durch den Schnee rennen soll ich noch
lauter, lauter machen. Der Sound ist halt allgemein nicht laut, ne?
Ja, Sound ist an. Ja, jetzt geht's, oder?
Okay, es ist kurz vorm Verrecken.
Kann man das Eifrieren klitschen, indem man diesen Pferderuf klitschen macht?
Oh, noch ein halbes Herz. Na gut, der wird's schaffen, weil wir wissen, das ist der Weltrekord.
Da kann man durchklitschen. Siehst du mal, das letzte Mal, wo ich in Any% Speed reingeguckt hab,
da haben die das alles noch gar nicht gemacht.
Kann man durchklitschen. Musste man die Dinger in der richtigen Reihenfolge normalerweise machen?
Zum Start? Oder konnte man die in der Reihenfolge machen, wie man will?
Also ohne Glitches.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Kommt man in eine beliebige Reihenfolge machen?
Okay, dann geht er einfach nur nicht durch die Tür, weil's schneller ist.
Okay, das Ding ist E. Das hat, glaub ich, schon jeder mal irgendwo in einem Video auf YouTube
gesehen. Dieses Chinesis oder wie auch immer dieses Ding. Das ist extrem OP für Speedruns.
Da kannst du ja Gegenstände einfrieren mit und die schlägst du dann an und dann fliegen
die across the map und du kannst dich dran festhalten. Deswegen holt er sich das wahrscheinlich
als erstes.
Okay, ich predikte mal was, Leute.
Bodrik, danke schön für den Prime-Sub. Ich predikte mal was. Der wird bis zum Ende des
Games keine Rüstung mehr anziehen. Oder was meint ihr? Wir werden uns jetzt 20 Minuten
nach Nackischen Link angucken. Passt Nackischen. Der zieht bis zum Schluss keine Rüstung an.
Okay, es waren jetzt schon ein paar heftige Sachen dabei, aber da geht bestimmt noch was.
Wie ist das bei Speedruns eigentlich? Spielen die alle auf der gleichen Version? Äh, nee,
je nach Spiel gibt's da unterschiedliche Kategorien für unterschiedliche Versionen. Aber in dem
Fall glaub schon, ja. Wo guckt der denn hin? Was ist da los?
Genau. Genau deswegen hat er sich das als erstes geholt.
Okay, ich sehe schon. Ab jetzt wird kein normaler Weg mehr gegangen.
Wie lange dauert das Game, wenn man so normal zockt? Boah, kannst du schon 43 Stunden spielen?
In your face. Was? Sekunde. Ich dachte, der killt die Gegner jetzt. Wait a minute. Wait
a minute. Was? What? Was so? Alter und er trifft genau dort, wo das nächste Schreien
steht. Poggers. Erstmal wieder schön durch die Tür klitschen. Jawoll. Das ist ja krass.
Boah, ey. Ich frag mich immer, wie die den Kram rausfinden. Ich mein, dass die den Kram
rausfinden, hab ich mich ja mittlerweile damit schon abgefunden. Aber ich frag mich immer,
wie... Mir ist, also ich geh mal davon aus, einige von euch haben das Spiel auch gespielt
und mir ist während des normalen Durchspielens absolut nie irgendwas Merkwürdiges passiert.
Alles genau so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab. Ich könnte wetten, denn
ab jetzt läuft er wirklich keinen normalen Weg mehr. Der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nur
across the map jumpen. Ach so, ja. Kein Thema. Wir Kacknoobs laufen da noch normal durch.
Was? Warum überhaupt? Wobei das halt auch cool ist. Wisst ihr, was man daran sieht
bei dem Game? Dass Nintendo die Sachen eben nicht durchgeskriptet hat, sondern... Nein,
ich spiel das doch nicht, WTF. Dass Nintendo die Sachen eben nicht komplett durchgeskriptet
hat, dass du quasi A machen musst, dass B passiert, sondern dass die sich komplett
auf ihre so Physik-Simulation und Welt verlassen, in der du dich frei bewegen kannst und wenn
du so komische Moves machen kannst, kannst du halt auch Sachen überspringen. Manche Spiele
kannst du ja mit so Dinger hoffnungslos klitschen, dass es gar nicht mehr weitergeht. Ich hab
gedacht, ich spiele auch sonst immer auf Französisch. Ich bin ja bekannter für Spiele, immer auf
Französisch zu spielen. Okay, Achtung. Jetzt wird er wahrscheinlich wieder springen. Nee.
Ah, nee. Ah, guck mal. Man muss die Dinger anscheinend anlocken, dass man von oben, man
muss denen auf den Kopf springen. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, wie dieser Klitsch funktioniert.
Ich rate mir da jetzt was zusammen. Man muss von oben auf die Gegner auf den Kopf springen
und dann mit nem Pfeil draufschießen und dann mit dem Shield vom Kopf des Gegners wegbouncen
oder so. Leute, meint ihr, der pausiert? Meint ihr, der pausiert oder die Switch kommt
nicht mit Nachladen hinterher? Macht der Pause oder hängt die Switch? Ich glaub, die Switch
hängt Nachladen, gibts ja ein Menü. Äh, Pause, gibts ja ein Menü. Nachladen ist halt,
die Switch hängt an einfach. Genau an der richtigen Stelle gelandet, easy. Safe lag.
Ach, unten links, stimmt, unten links die Erlader-Animation, ja. Fallschaden, Fallschaden
kann man cancelen, wenn man glaub ich im richtigen Moment die Waffe wegsteckt oder sowas. Oder
Waffe wechselt, irgendwas war da, hab ich mal gelesen. Also Fallschaden kann man cancelen,
das wusste ich. Ja, muss ich mal überlegen. Ich glaub, ich hab 40 Stunden in dem Spiel
rumgewurstet. Ich hab auch relativ viel gemacht. Okay, da rennt er jetzt einfach vorbei, ja,
das war klar. Ich mein, bei den meisten Speedruns, wo es nicht notwendig ist, werden ja Gegner
prinzipiell nicht bekämpft. Ich muss echt sagen, das hat mit dem Any% Speedrun, den
ich mal vor 2 Jahren oder so geguckt hab, oder vor 1,5 Jahren, nicht mehr allzu viel
zu tun. Also da wurden wohl verdammt viele Glitches gefunden in der Zwischenzeit, dass
man quasi gar nicht mehr über die Map laufen muss. Und was mir da immer auffällt, wie gut
das Spiel auf der Switch aussieht, ne. So, jetzt erstmal wieder ne Kiste festhalten.
Warum schießt der eigentlich? Okay, ich versuch das mal zu verstehen. Ich geh mal davon aus,
die Schläge, die er am Anfang macht, die sind rein zum Aufladen da. Und der letzte
Damage bestimmt die Richtung. Und der nimmt den Bogen, weil du damit am besten aimen kannst.
Vermute ich jetzt, ja okay, der Chat kennt sich da anscheinend aus. Ne, Falldamage gibt's
ja aus, prinzipiell nicht. Erstmal Falldamage cancel. Den letzten Speedrun, den ich geguckt
hab, da haben die sich noch was gekocht, dass die nicht erfrieren und sowas. Obvious, basic
movement, basic movement, wer macht's nicht. Ja, wieder durchgeklitscht. Schon heftig was
die da mittlerweile rausgefunden haben. Übrigens, in 10 Minuten ist das Spiel durchgespielt.
Und ich glaube, ich glaube auch, ich hab mal ein Video drüber gesehen, du musst diese
ersten vier Schreien machen. Nicht weil du nicht den Endboss schaffen würdest, sondern
weil das Spiel sonst, das lässt dich nicht dieses Gebiet verlassen. Du kannst da zwar
rausklitschen und rüberfliegen und sonst wie, aber die Welt funktioniert nicht richtig
und du wirst dann irgendwie wieder zurückgebeamt und sowas. Du kannst nicht runterklitschen
hier von diesem Startgebiet, deswegen müssen die diese vier ersten Dungeons machen, bis
sie den Kleider kriegen. Also dieses Segelding.
Oh, what the? Ahja, easy movement. Sekunde, das muss ich mir noch mal angucken. Ja klar,
so hab ich das auch durchgespielt, also so hab ich das auch gemacht. First try, beim
ersten Play, keine Frage. Alter, was Zeug. Easy hab ich auch so gemacht, wer nicht, wer
nicht, ich glaube die meisten haben das so gemacht. Stimmt, der hat nur noch ¼ Herz,
das ist garantiert so getimed. Also das ist wahrscheinlich echt so geplant. Hier die
Animation. Ja, alles klar.
Leute, diesen Klitsch hab ich nie ausprobiert. Wie schwer ist es das so geaimt zu bekommen?
Ich kann es mir wirklich schlecht vorstellen. Das kann von, mit ein bisschen Übung kriegt
es irgendwie jeder hin, zumindest reproduzierbar, ich mein jetzt nicht, dass es jedes Mal funktioniert,
aber reproduzierbar, oder ist das fucking schwer? Ich mein, der muss ja das so aimen,
also die Reichweite und die Richtung muss stimmen. Sehr schwer, ok. So, jetzt kriegt
er sein Kleider gleich und dann kann er zum Endgegner. Easy, würde ich mal sagen. Ich
muss dir sagen, ich fand Breath of the Wild schon ein geiles Game, aber es ist weit davon
entfernt mein Lieblingstelder zu sein. Unpopuläre Meinung, ich weiß mittlerweile, das wird ja
in allen Stellen bis zum Umfallen gefeiert, aber mein Lieblingstelder ist es nicht, auch
weiter von weg. Es ist mir einfach viel zu wenig klassisches Zelda gewesen, aber gut,
das ist sicherlich Geschmackssache. Vor allem hat mir der Soundtrack gefehlt. Ah ja, wir
fliegen erstmal. Der fliegt jetzt nicht wirklich bis zum Schloss durch, oder? Achso. Ja, einfach
mal vom Startgebiet bis zum Endgegner durchfliegen, kein Problem. Nee, mein Lieblingstelder ist
auch nicht Ocarina of Time, mein Lieblingstelder ist halbe halbe A Link to the Past und Majora's
Quest. Er landet auch noch genau beim Eingang, wo er hin muss. Warum macht er den Endgegner
nicht als erstes? Weil das Spiel dich zurück teleportiert, wenn du versuchst rauszuspringen.
Der könnte das von Anfang an machen, aber das Spiel ist halt noch im Tutorial-Modus
und du kannst nicht raus. Jetzt hat er ein paar Waffen gelootet. Gut, er braucht hier
irgendwas, um den Endgegner zu killen. Wollte ich gerade sagen, wie will er den Endgegner
platt kriegen mit seiner Startwaffe? Ist das Amiibo? Äh, Leute, ich hab diese Amiibo-Geschichte
nie ausprobiert. Ist das in irgendeiner Art? Ja, das ist Amiibo. Was ist denn das für
ein Amiibo-Ding? Eine Truhe mit Fisch? Was für ein Amiibo ist das, was der da aufhebt?
Ich hab's nie verwendet, kein Schimmer. Amiibo-Stonks. Pay to win, Leute! Pay to win! Du musst ein
Amiibo kaufen, dass du World Record Speedrun machen kannst. Jetzt sind auch schon Speedruns
pay to win. Ach, die Gegner rennen den Bomben nach? Wusstet ihr das? Ich hatte keinen plassen
Schimmer, dass die Gegner diesen Bomben nachrennen. Dass man die damit tricksen kann, in die andere
Richtung zu gucken. Wusste ich überhaupt nicht. Ich hab ab und zu mal ein paar Gegner Bomben
da gegen den Kopf geschmissen. So diese Magic-Bomben. Ah, ok, mal schön Wall Clipped. Aber ich
wusste gar nicht, dass die da nachrennen. Stimmt, man könnte den NFC-Text sogar selber
beschriften. Du brauchst eigentlich gar kein Amiibo. Dann legst du einfach einen NFC-Tag
drauf. Ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser, als sich einen Amiibo zu kaufen, wenn man den
nicht so schon hat. Man kann die Gegner mit den Bomben ablenken. Das wusste ich gar
nicht. Lässt ihr mal, Noob. Tell der Noob hier.
Ja gut, dass ihm die Steuerung angezeigt wird. Er wüsste es sicherlich nicht weiter. Was
gibt das, wenn es fertig ist? Wait a minute. Ich kann mich nicht mal dran erinnern, wie
das normalerweise funktioniert hat. Aber war das nicht so, wenn du reinläufst in das...
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Zumindest so war das nicht. Ok, easy two hit wahrscheinlich
jetzt. Das geht nicht. Das funktioniert nicht. Du kannst nicht... Die Frage, was dauert länger
laufen ohne Kleider? Das geht nicht. Du kommst aus dem Startgebiet nicht raus. Du könntest
dich theoretisch aus dem Startgebiet rausklitschen, aber das Spiel ist, solange du den Kleider
noch nicht hast, im Tutorial-Modus. Du kannst nichts machen, solange das Spiel im Tutorial-Modus
ist. Du musst die ersten vier Dungeons machen, bis du den Kleider bekommst. Ja, das Ende
von Breath of the Wild ist Fail. Das ist viel zu kurz. Die sagen dann so nach dem Motto,
ja wir bauen Hyrule wieder auf und alles ist gut und fertig. Das Ende war kacke. Zumal
gerade ab jetzt das Spiel wenigstens ein halbwegs gescheites Soundtrack hatte. Das Spiel hatte
die ganze Zeit über keinen richtigen Soundtrack, halt ein bisschen Klaviergedöns. Ich weiß,
es soll so sein, aber mir persönlich hat es halt nicht gefallen. Und gerade ab jetzt
hat das Spiel wieder einen ordentlichen Soundtrack, ja? Und dann ist es einfach fertig. Der hat
das Timing schon echt drauf, der Kerl, ne? Der hat das Timing mit den Hits schon echt
drauf, weil ich mein, einmal getroffen und das Game ist vorbei. Ich mein, er hat keine
Rüstung an, er hat zwei Herzen. Er überlebt definitiv nicht auch nur einmal an Husten
vom Gegner. Ne, das Spiel ist nicht spanisch, das Spiel
ist glaube ich französisch eingestellt. Ach, das ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es
gesehen habe oder ich weiß nicht, ob ich es richtig gesehen habe. Guck mal, der hat
das vom Timing auch genau hin. Jetzt ist seine Waffe kaputt, jetzt ist seine Waffe kaputt.
Moment, Moment, ne, warte mal. Jetzt ist die Waffe kaputt und jetzt wirft er, also jetzt
hat die Waffe noch einen Damage, jetzt wirft er die Waffe gegen den Gegner und jetzt bricht
die Waffe und macht extra Damage. Das ist heftig, heftiges Timing, kann man es nicht
nennen, aber Resource Management oder sowas. Calculated, genau. Es steht gut, dass er keine
Rüstung anzieht, ne, das ist sicher, der zieht keine Rüstung an, kostet doch Zeit,
der zieht ja keine Rüstung an. Boomerang, Leute, was ist hier los? Der Boomerang. Schreckt,
get schreckt. Das Spiel äußerst agil. Gut, also eins muss man ja mal sagen, schwer waren
die Fights wirklich nett. Sogar für meine Boomer-Switch-Skills war das relativ easy,
aber ich hatte halt auch ordentliches Gier. Ja, Riggs-Mode sehe ich genauso. Also der Boss-Fight
war easy as fuck und gerade das, was danach jetzt kommt, war noch viel, viel easier. Also
da kannst du jetzt ja sogar noch sterben, aber dem, was danach kommt, kannst du eigentlich
gar nicht mehr sterben. Okay, wahrscheinlich wird das wieder genauso
Zeit, dass er den hittet und dann mit der kaputten, jetzt wirft er die kaputte Waffe,
ne? Bam. Das ist wirklich cooles Timing. Der schlägt die Waffe so kaputt, dass sie quasi
eins vor dem letzten Hit ist, wirft sie gegen den Gegner, die Waffe bricht und macht den
Gegner, finished den Gegner. Also das ist echt eine Jubel, das hat er bestimmt doch
schon einige Male geübt, dass das so gut klappt. Kommt ja bald der zweite Teil, also
bei Nintendo bald, ja. Okay, das ist jetzt Absicht, dass er mehrere
Hits macht. Und jetzt Waffe werfen gleich wahrscheinlich, gleich noch Waffe oder auch nicht. Waffe werfen,
Waffe? Okay, Waffe wird nicht mehr geworfen, es wird Kreisel-Crime gemacht. Easy Kreisler.
Easy Kogos gemacht. Ja, der Gegner war jetzt easy. Also chat, ich weiß nicht, wer ist gespielt,
ist da jemand wirklich gestorben? Da kannst du eigentlich nicht mehr sterben, das geht
nicht. Du reitest da ein bisschen im Kreis rum und schießt auf leuchtende Punkte. Was
gibt das, wenn es fertig ist? Die machen da übrigens auf Drama, aber der Boss ist so
extrem easy. Link, die französische Aussprache von Link ist auch geil. Link, ich kann das
gar nicht nachmachen. Ja, du reitest einfach rum und schießt auf leuchtende Dinge. Das
war easy. So, jetzt musst du noch unter den Bauch reiten gleich. Nee, erst noch mal die
andere Seite und dann unter den Bauch reiten und dann in your face und dann ist fertig.
Also das war zu easy. Das fand ich war viel zu easy. Bester Boss Kampf, also bester Endboss
Kampf. Alle Zelda Spiele ist für mich der aus Twilight Princess. Der ist wirklich nice
gemacht. By the way, das war der Boss jetzt schon. Jetzt musst du einmal unter den Bauch
reiten, noch mal draufschießen, fertig. Viel zu einfach gewesen. Wie er einfach schon
weiß, was er wie wo machen muss. So nach dem Motto, ich bleibe jetzt einfach da stehen,
bis der Skript startet und dann bam. Aber Twilight Princess, der letzte Boss, der war
wirklich extrem geil. Link! Achtung, Baguette Error. Okay, easy, win.
Time. Krasser Scheiß, oder? Da waren schon ein paar heftige Dinge dabei. Wobei man halt
sagen muss, also, sofern die es nicht doch noch irgendwie schaffen, dass man die ersten
Dungeons skippen kann, so viel schneller kannst du es doch gar nicht mehr machen, oder? Es
ist ja noch nicht so, dass die da noch irgendwie zwei, drei Minuten oder so runter, wo soll
der zwei, drei Minuten sparen noch? Also das geht höchstens nur, wenn die wieder irgendwelche
noch abgedrehtere Sachen finden an Glitches. Übrigens jetzt nochmal, Twilight Princess
fight, der war poggers. Also da konntest du echt nichts sagen. Monkeys, zu laut. Also
Twilight Princess hatte mit Abstand den besten Bosskampf. So du hast erstmal, ich mach das
jetzt, wir gucken jetzt keine 38 Minuten, ne? Sorry für Spoiler, wer Twilight Princess
noch nicht gespielt hat. So, du musst jetzt erstmal Massive Bosskampf machen gegen, okay
die Zelda Battle war dumm. So, du musst erstmal gegen so ein komisches Vieh kämpfen. Das musst
du bashen. Das musst du bashen, so. Gute Mini-Musik, Nintendo Mini-Musik, jawoll. Du musst halt
das Beast bashen und das musst du auf die Seite werfen und dann den Bauch bashen, okay.
So, danach, wenn du das geschafft hast, dann hast du irgendwie erstmal Zelda befreit und
dann kommst du auf so ein Feld. So, dann musst du mit Zelda jetzt noch eine Weile rumreiten
und musst dem hinterher rennen und mit Lichtpfeilen abschießen, okay. Aber das geilste Battle
kommt am Schluss. Jaja, bisschen Story überspringen. Genau, jetzt musst du ihn erstmal weg bashen
mit Lichtpfeilen, okay. Aber da warst du eh schon ultra gehyped danach, aber das beste
Battle kommt, wenn du ihn gekillt hast vom Pferd. Und da ist, finde ich, kein Zelda
bisher herangekommen an diesen Bossfight am Ende. Ach guck mal, ist gut, der schneit
jetzt raus, der schneit jetzt raus. Exzellent. Bam. So, jetzt kommt der epischste Bossfight,
den sie bisher in Zelda hingekriegt haben. Du schießt ihn runter und du denkst, ja okay,
vielleicht hast du es jetzt geschafft. Er steht da halt nochmal auf und macht seine
komischen Geräusche, die er dann immer macht. Übrigens, alle, alle, die müssen immer lachen,
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, was es damit ist, warum irgendwie so die Masterminds
da immer böse machen, weil sie immer lachen müssen, aber okay. Da gab es noch kein Voice
Acting. Und deswegen finde ich, ist das mit Abstand der beste, also ich finde ihn sogar
noch besser als den Ocarina of Time Schlussbattle, weil du zum ersten Mal, mir fällt auch danach
kein anderes Zelda ein, in dieser Anweise, wo du wirklich one on one fighten musst als
Endboss. Das fand ich richtig geil gemacht damals, mir ging da voll einer dabei ab.
Ja. Jetzt stimmt Wind Waker, Wind Waker, klar, Wind Waker, hast recht, ja. Aber Wind
Waker war bei weitem nicht so epischer Fight, wie der ganze Stealth hier. Nee, Skyward Sword
war ja nicht mal Ganon, Skyward Sword war dieser komische Ganon Vorläufer, der, wo du
vor lauter Lichteffekten epileptische Anfälle gekriegt hast. Auf jeden Fall ultra nice,
der Boss Fight. Ja gut, am Ende, ich meine, ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie das Ganze
aufhört, du bashst ihn und dann ist gut, ja. Bester, aber ich fand, bester Boss Fight
überhaupt, so in jede, also auf die, auf diese Serie beschränkt. Ja, nice. So, das, ich
weiß komplett off Topic, aber das muss jetzt auch mal sein. Ich speicher mir mal den ganzen
Kram. Äh, hatte ich hier noch irgendwelche Tabs? Tetris? Wollte ich mir auch noch angucken?
Okay, zack, zack, save, all Tabs. Ja, ähm, exzellent. So Leute, ich muss ins Bett, wir
sehen uns morgen. Oh ja, du bist leider ein bisschen spät. Dankeschön für den Sub,
bambabum, Dings, Bums, Babums, elf Monate, fast schon Hyper Subscription. Ähm, mein
New Block ist nicht im Hard Mode, wie kann man den in Hard Mode setzen? Wie, wie setzt
man den in Hard Mode? Ich, ich, äh, hab ihn an. Ach, alle Third-Parties-Blocken, ja, da
gehen ja die Hälfte der Seiten nicht mehr. Äh, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt YouTube
sag, wir blocken hier... Wo stellt man überhaupt Hard Mode ein? Ach so, du meinst das? Äh,
passt schon. Alles klar Leute, ich bin weg, bis denn, CU.